every single Arc quite literally details
like leftist politics which I think Oda
is Oda is 100 leftist first of all Luffy
is a terrorist
hello welcome back to another episode of
the trash taste podcast uh I'm Joe and
I'm with the boys as per usual and uh I
have an absolute Giga Chad sitting next
to me uh introduce yourself what's up
everybody I'm assault [__] also known
as hassanabi uh yeah and you normally
talk about politics but we're gonna talk
about anime instead yeah that's what the
real politics is because we have found
out Hassan is probably a massive week he
tries he tries to play it down but I
think he's a bigger weave than some
people in this room I'll be honest I
don't know what these guys are talking
about dude literally literally off since
the song was like I've got assets so I'm
ready to go
oh I have a lot of I have a lot of great
takes about anime that are spicy but
okay the only reason why I came on is
because they said like oh trash day is
like they they talk about podcasts the
first five episodes they stopped yeah
yeah so that's why I was like oh thank
God okay they're like a reformed weeb
Community
showing that weebs can function in
society yeah it's important to show that
yeah like yeah normally I would go for
you know permanent jail but you know
it's okay
we're the only three in all of Japan
that are functioning weebs yeah exactly
so I guess this is going to be one of
the most uh anime heavy guest episodes
we've had on trash day so there we go
most likely yeah the thought I got some
you sure we have a Vash the Stampede
statue yeah and you were like I should
draw him what yeah oh yeah I used to
draw all the time when I was younger
like I my dad basically put an end to it
he was like you're not gonna make money
doing this
yeah I literally that's all I did when I
was in high school of just sit down math
class I was just a draw right on my
notebook and this is before you actually
watch try on right no no this is well I
just watched the Remake I just started
watching it right but yeah I had seen
Snippets of Trigon I never actually
watched anime but I thought it was so
sick like I thought the characters look
so cool yeah yeah this does look cool
yeah Vash is like such a sick looking
character love the gun and then also the
the cross gun too the rail oh yeah
that's wolf Woods one yeah so I would
literally draw characters from Trigun
all the time without actually ever
watching it yeah but recently I watched
it and it's so good yeah yeah it's one
of the especially if you're watching the
Remake it's one of the few 3D anime that
actually look really [__] good as
well they use the 3D really really well
on that and it's like full 3d which is
unique you know because the last time I
saw a full 3D anime I think I swore off
anime for good it was the berserk
I'm sorry I'm sorry I think I'm good I'm
never gonna wanna watch
do you not only watch the 3D anime you
watch probably one of the worst oh yeah
yeah yeah I know literally starting at
the bottom yeah oh my God
and now
[Laughter]
okay thanks all right
um yeah like uh I mean obviously they
use assets like they do 3D
backgrounds and things like that yeah
and you know you can Tastefully put that
in there sometimes but this is like
full-blown CGI exactly and I wasn't
expecting much from it and I casually
downloaded it right before the flight
and then instead of watching One Piece I
literally watched all of the all of the
episodes so good oh I haven't finished
it yet but yeah yeah yeah I mean Trigon
I think is I I don't know I I had in my
mind I wasn't sure if it aged well but
watching the Remake I'm like okay this
is a banger story a banger setting as
well not a continuation no it's a remake
remake yeah
so you can watch it as well I've already
watched the first one oh okay okay I
remember I had a very weird ending
though yeah yeah very 80s ending yeah
yeah I won't spoil it obviously because
I I just legit don't know speaking of
not aging well okay I got some anime
takes
you so excited okay first of all I this
is this is gonna be contentious okay
yeah Dragon Ball Z does not age well oh
the anime yeah yeah absolutely okay good
yeah
because like I talk about this stuff in
my community all the time and I'm like
dude shut the [__] up stick to politics
yeah they're like they're like very mad
at me but the thing is Dragon Ball fans
are some of the most passionate fans you
can find yeah oh yeah so we love
clowning on Dragon Ball fans maybe a bit
too much uh sometimes actually I mean
it's so easy yeah it was my first like
actual anime that I watched that I
really got into anime with yeah Dragon
Ball and Dragon Ball Z yeah and um I you
know I I rewatched it I tried rewatching
it recently thinking like oh it's gonna
be sick and then I realized like oh as a
kid when I was watching it
I was basically making up most of the
fight suit because in my mind it was
like a puzzle piece that was missing
that was my own imagination yeah because
like when you're a kid you're like
thinking oh this is so well drawn yeah
and then you watch it and they're
reusing assets like crazy like the
punches oh yeah yeah yeah and and in my
mind I'm thinking they're like throwing
blows and like dodging you know what I
mean turns out like that wasn't the case
at all and then a fight sequence was
like 11 episodes yeah yeah you have like
five episodes of just them powering up
yeah yeah and then you're like two
episodes are staring down yeah and
you're like as a kid this felt like 20
30 minutes yeah it was like 30 episodes
or something yeah how much skipping is
like allowed until you're basically just
not watching it at that point because I
feel like if you wanted to skim through
it and just skip through it's like I
guess for Dragon Ball yeah it's very
hard to stop at any point and feel like
you're getting content right so it'll
just like spread out yeah so yeah I mean
I we've talked about Dragon Ball Z
quality on this podcast and uh I you
know it's it has its lineage it started
a lot of Shonen anime it's [__]
incredible I would not rewatch Dragon
Ball Z yeah no I mean it was literally
my entry point in anime the first ever
anime I actually watched was dubbed in
turkey when I was growing up oh [__]
subasa
um
hell yeah and I don't really like soccer
like that I don't really you know I
don't really [__] with football and
um but because turkey loves football
they probably thought like this is a
sick [__] this is a sick show to like
distribute yeah yeah um and it was
dubbed it was dubbed in Turkish right
okay and I did not like it at all so I
just never really watched any anime
because I thought it was all like random
soccer
and thank God for Dragon Ball me back in
was was the anime scene big in Turkey
did you get a lot of exposure to anime I
wouldn't imagine so like I didn't even
understand the distinction between anime
and like Western rides like Western
animated shows yeah at all like I just
thought it was another drawn show with
like weird eyes well because it was
probably all on like the same channel as
like all the other Western cartoons as
well yeah yeah yeah exactly growing up
when I was watching it you I like
obviously maybe some Western consuming
my own shows targeted towards me it
definitely felt like they were really
different and you couldn't really
pinpoint why yeah dumb kids yeah you
understand the concept of dubbing yeah
dubbing just seems like magic yeah yeah
other languages exist no no no no no
well there wasn't that much like um I'm
thinking about it now there wasn't
exactly like a lot of Turkish cartoons
anyway so like everything is dubbed yeah
um so for me like I said I just thought
it was like a little bit different yeah
it was the same thing and then I
realized when I came to America and like
saw all this like different branching
out between anime and and you know
that's when I realized like oh this is
totally sick yeah yeah what was the
anime you watched after Dragon Ball Z
then
I mean I don't know I
ones that are most memorable and are all
also in my top anime so probably like
Cowboy Bebop and Samurai okay yeah a lot
of stuff I watched I watched off of when
I came to America in a summer or
something because like there's no anime
when I was growing up in Turkey yeah at
all yeah except for to Tsubasa for some
reason
um
so uh it was all it was all like what is
it called Toonami it's like tsunami I
don't swim yeah yeah it's also in
tsunami stuff yeah so whatever they had
on at night that's what I kind of got
into
um but you know so when did you actually
start getting into anime and don't say
you're not don't say you're not because
I mean I so I I read like uh I read the
Naruto mangas when they would uh come
out like in America when I was in
America in the summer certified weave
right there yeah all right the fact that
you went to the manga yeah yeah yeah
well because for me it was like I love
this content it's so unique it's so
different and I can't get it in Turkey
so like I would go to I would park up at
like a borders yeah literally I would go
to like a Borders or Barnes and Noble
and I was like oh damn like you could
just like sit here all day and just read
these books yeah like that's crazy
because like at the time I'm old I'm I'm
you know I'm 31 years old so like at the
time I didn't even really think about
how I could like like we didn't have
access to distribution networks like we
do now you know you got lime wire and
[__] but like yeah that's half the time
you're downloading malware on the family
computer yeah yeah so I didn't know
um I didn't I didn't know how to like
access it so I would just like consume
it as much as I could yeah you got what
you took uh yeah yeah and uh yeah that
was that was very similar if you tried
downloading anime offline wire most of
the time it was just oh yeah yeah most
of the time it was either out of order
or hentai it was Bill Clinton or Bill
Clinton yeah a lot of Bill Clinton yeah
it was yeah I I also never really got
into digital uh I can't do the digital
reading like it has to be I don't know
it has to be physical I'm exactly the
same yeah it's just for some reason it
doesn't hit for me yeah it used to I
used to be like physical only and I
think reading on a tablet has like
offset that a bit I cannot read on a
phone phone is like way too small of a
screen
is like a lot of manga don't get adapted
nearly quick enough like Jojo for
example in English is like I think
they're just starting part five oh [__]
already the official English translation
geez we have like part five dub of the
anime before we had part five English in
the manga that's so weird because I
don't know why I don't know why it's
taking so long like distribution
probably a bigger audience how does it's
insane that it takes that long oh in the
case of Jojo they're probably reading
and they're just like what the [__] is
this like how the hell am I supposed to
translate is this allowed yeah I was
like [__] we gotta we gotta they have
like board meetings for how to change
the band names yeah yeah yeah this is
copyright infringement the manga oh yeah
how does that work in Japan like they
just they don't care about like Western
copy right they just run it I think they
just kind of like turn the Blind Eye
maybe in a lot of ways I don't think
it's more so that the American one would
have a problem I think it's just more of
a like it's a it's just a just do it
just in case like change it yeah because
why why even risk it because there's so
many band names where it's like maybe it
feels warm we could maybe let it slide
yeah but when the whole show has like
Pink Floyd
the Rolling Stone it's like all right
guys I think one of them's gonna get
pissed off yeah yeah I'm honestly
surprised there hasn't been a band that
has found JoJo on a whim and just being
like that we didn't we didn't give them
permission to do this sleep what what
the [__] I mean it would be super
[__] lame if you were like yeah I
don't want it in that it's like it's
literally the coolest thing ever or they
find it and they start reading they're
like oh this is actually kind of sick
yeah you don't want to piss off JoJo
fans because
they will come to your house and burn it
down you know have you seen already I
have I watched the JoJo ones up to uh
the last one on Netflix yeah I guess
part six like Florida I saw some of the
Florida prison one
um I haven't finished it yet though yeah
um but yeah no I've I do you [__] with
it yeah no I love JoJo it's weird as
[__]
um I have a bad tank according to Connor
I tell people not to watch part one yeah
okay well I'll tell people like it's a
little I mean it's very different
it's like a different show that they
made for some reason obviously there's
backbone there you know like the port
another food and you know the speed
wagon or not part of the speed wagon and
you know everyone else like the whole
family lineage is established there but
like other than that it's like a
different anime yeah yeah but it's nice
you gotta you get you get like rewarded
for watching and I feel like you can
appreciate the show more yeah for wildly
changing it up but then also having
little crumbs that kind of like rewards
yeah especially when you get to like the
latest like seven and eight where it's
where actually they start to call back
to stuff in part one it's like oh okay
it's 100 part six you know and they're
doing all this weird [__] [__] that
makes no sense already because they
don't explain stands ever yeah because
like why would they because you've
watched part three yeah right and then
they're like oh and then we're gonna get
the we're gonna get the stand to the
speed wagon Foundation it's like what
does any of these words yeah no you have
to watch that's what I mean though like
you just establish him as a character
and like but then after that it's like
it just drops you into this world oh the
fighting sequence has changed completely
like that's cool I guess yeah I mean I
really like it because I it's like even
though Paul one is my least favorite
part it's kind of like a time stamp of
the era that I was made in right you
know it's very reminiscent of the OG 80s
action movie yes everyone's like overly
buff and everyone's like a giga chat I
love it I slowly but get less gigger
Chad over yeah yeah yeah I mean I like
it though I like that it's they're all
evolving yeah yeah for sure yeah which
one's your favorite part ooh
my favorite is Cujo so I probably like
six
is is that part six well oh no sorry
Cujo oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah so like Kira and all of
that that's possible
is in part four as well yeah
right with the pompadour yeah yeah oh no
no no not Jose no no no with the hataro
yeah that's positive he's in part three
four and six and six yeah yeah do you
just like him I just like him he's my
favorite he is the most popular yeah
okay that makes sense but I think in
Japan Dio is the most popular character
really yeah well he's probably like the
biggest reoccurring character outside of
it he turns into everything Japan loves
the bad boys man yeah they do they do
that's exactly that's surprising but
that's because he's like uh because he's
like super charismatic and crazy
he's like psychotic Japan loves
psychotic characters would like why
would you root for the bad guy that
makes no sense what no because he's epic
I love him what the
[__] stage presence you know and the
the Japanese voices are so goddamn good
yeah uh it's so [__] good yeah I
think it's just just because he is you
know Japan being like a very let's say a
very quiet Society they love someone
who's like more eccentric shows himself
we do like this [__] annoying like
you know my first experience with JoJo
walls it was the [__] Steam Sale
edits where they would have you seen
these oh yeah yeah like uh they would
have these meme edits where it was like
a steam when back when steam Steam Sale
was a big meme yeah obviously it's
always everything's Dirt Cheap yeah and
they would do like the final fight in
part three yeah versus jotro and it
would just be like because he screams
muda so many times yeah just like
throwing More Steam Sale memes at like
another sale another sale that's the
first time you ever saw JoJo it was the
first time
as a meme and I just didn't understand
that's how it kind of discovers most
things yeah yeah because it was like I
was like what the [__] is this and then
there's this dude screaming and there's
and JoJo's like the wallet and Dio is
like the money like the guy take the
steams yeah I have no idea how I got
into JoJo yeah how did you I don't know
I literally have no because it's like
it's like one of those things where it's
so popular and it has like an annoying
fan base yeah so then like kind of like
one piece as a matter of fact I would
say is that is that how is that how you
get into anime are you just like you get
I get bullied into it you get bullied
yeah no no no I don't think JoJo was
like you have to watch this like
um but it just I don't know well yeah
because JoJo fans have like the
reputation of being the annoying fan
base oh yeah never being able to shut up
about the show yeah which is totally
true by the way but that's like every I
feel like there's every anime fan base
one piece love to pretend they're not
like that but one piece fancy oh my God
one piece is way I promise you like if
someone watched Jojo and is currently
watching One Piece yeah one piece was
way worse with respect to like how much
they were like bro you you have to watch
One Piece and it's such a it's like a
Biblical text like
it's too many episodes so you're like I
don't have that kind of time yeah we're
talking I'm on the New Testament yeah
yeah yeah it's like I don't have that
kind of time commitment like I can't do
this and then and then you get into it
and you're like oh my God it's so good
yeah I have people now in my fan base
that just like don't know me for
politics but just like listen to me talk
about one piece because like there's I
have thousands of fan channels on
YouTube right like I don't have any IP
or anything so I'm like whatever you
know let it ride who cares yeah yeah
there's this one fan channel that made
an edit
um about how I like used to talk [__]
about one piece and I started watching
it yeah and those videos independently
this Channel's got like 10K subs or
something like nothing crazy yeah that
video got like hundred thousand views on
its own and now he's just like detailing
and documenting every single episode and
every single Arc that I like summarize
basically as I'm watching it and like
there is a fan base for that oh yeah one
piece yeah everything which is a very
political anime Conor that's okay it is
a very political what he told me one
piece is very political yes what aspect
oh my God yes I love this okay this is
gonna piss off everybody but I'm so
right about this even though like
okay like okay first of all every single
Arc well other than like the first
couple of arcs every single Arc quite
literally details like leftist politics
which I think Oda is Oda is 100 Oda is
100 left is first of all
he has Jake he has a Che Guevara photo
in a studio 100 look it up establish
fact I have assets I can pull it up okay
okay what else what else okay so that's
number one number two which Arc are you
on I don't want to like spoil anything
he's uh yeah
yeah okay
um so Thriller bark kind of sucks I'm
sorry to hear that that's uh the ending
is great but like everything else is
kind of mid but it's fine because what
comes after is
that means you watch like you watch
Alabaster right yeah which is definitely
political but like not as aggressively
but it's about like resource deprivation
things like that but then Sky Pia which
again may be a little bit too long as an
arc is quite literally about like you
know indigenous uh populations being
removed from their land and like
violently trying to to to uh you know
find autonomy and emancipation through
you know through violent means directly
against like an enemy that is much more
powerful to them right that is like you
know that's like a land back movement
which is inherently very political very
leftist
um I've watched a different I read it
yeah I know I I was trying to describe
this to him he's like what are you
talking about it's like man I saw funny
gum men yeah yeah one piece about having
fun with your friends and being free
yeah exactly I mean first of all Luffy
is a terrorist
I mean he's fighting I I hate that
you're kind of right yes I [__] hate
that you're kind of right yeah he is a
freedom fighter in the in the most like
honorable sense of the word he is quite
literally fighting against an
unjustifiable corrupt military apparatus
that is like holding the entire world
hostage the world government and the
Navy he's literally killing cops like
like he's killing sea cops and
[__] are like no no that's not
politics what do you mean that's just
like gum man having fun I mean the thing
is like I remember you saying this
yesterday when we were having dinner and
I was just like
um I I mean I I think with one piece
just because of the art style and just
the way things are ha funny rubber man
of course you know you can you can take
it at that level and it's still very
very interesting stories but if you
break down some of the stuff that
happens half of it is uh Luffy going up
against a corrupt government or corrupt
yeah I mean like you need to start an
anime analysis Channel I would
legitimately watch like a 15 minute
breakdown yeah
Hogwarts Legacy
yeah
it's I'm not even well there's like
there's a there's trans representation
in that too but we're not gonna get into
that right now yeah but
um as far as like uh Oda goes I mean
here there is the uh I think like
dragons does I mean I don't want to like
spoil anything but
um Oda Oda has talked about how dragon's
design was inspired in part by a
revolutionaries like Fidel Castro yeah
he has a Che Guevara photo in his in his
uh office I believe okay I don't know
this part yet I'm not at that part yet
so I can't speak on this but I think
dragon's ship is literally the same name
as Fidel Castro's ship okay but here's
the thing here's the thing
um I think sometimes you know especially
when you see this a lot in Japanese
manga sometimes authors will put [__] in
there just because it looks cool oh yeah
right sometimes it's there there it's
it's like you know the curtain is blue
kind of like argument sometimes you look
at something and it's a reference to uh
some Western Media or Western history
and a lot of the times it's just
Japanese people find Western things that
a fun question no no it's too many it's
too many coincidences listen listen
listen the bolivaran revolution in Cuba
was conducted with a yacht that will use
to transport 82 fighters of the Cuban
Revolution from Mexico to Cuba okay okay
the yacht's name is Grandma
without a d Grandma which is the exact
same uh is the exact same name as a
dragon's ship
like that's come on that's not like that
he didn't just see that and was like
because like you have to be like really
invested you have to be a weeb for
communism to like put that in there I
think he's just a weed for history
honestly like yeah with with the amount
of lore that one piece has like one
piece has some of the most intricate
World building in your opinion any piece
of media oh absolutely like it's it's
obviously one of the most intricate
worlds in anime and manga but I think
it's up there with like some of the best
worlds I've been in any like book movie
or TV series yeah right and you you
can't do that without doing a [__] ton
of history on just the history of the
world yeah yes being for sure being
inspired by a lot of events that might
have taken place uh in real world
history I'm just saying it points too
many fingers in One Direction oh here's
a here's a photo from oda's Office Space
where he has like uh his airsoft guns
and then like a photo of Che Guevara
right now I'm just saying dude he's got
prepared
it's really popular I'm sure it's true
yeah well anyway so that's that's
definitely that's definitely a spicy one
because like a lot of people watch anime
and like don't really think about like
who's making it or how they're making it
or what they intend to do with their art
so like I know a lot of people will
watch that and still be like yo [__]
that that's all I think a lot of people
view anime as being almost uh
non-political yeah an escape from yeah
yeah I think people view it that way I
mean which brings me to Finland Saga
chapter two season two okay so you like
Saga I love inless August Saga is
incredible amazing we talked you did an
interview with the with the author of it
yeah yeah is that the right term yeah
and
um it's really interesting when he told
you uh especially because like the first
season was sick yeah and the second
season is just like all about farming
for some reason
and then you're like out farming it's
more it's a majority of them but it's
not about just farming what's actually
really interesting about that is
in that in in the second season there
are very clear uh class Dynamics at play
like class in the marxian sense yeah
where the uh indentured serve uh the
endangered servants the slaves right
um are are undermined by The Peasants
yeah yeah even though the owner of the
farm is very nice to the slaves in
comparison to how mean he could be
technically and this might change but
this is as far as I've seen so far in
the second season and I I didn't read it
so I don't know but
um there there's a moment where uh you
know thorphin is talking to the other
slave
and the other slave is like these
peasants they're they're bullying us but
they don't realize that like they're in
the same position they own no land but
the reason why they're doing this to us
the reason why they're like stealing our
food or undermining us or not giving us
horses and whatnot is because it makes
them feel like they have some kind of
lordship over us right yeah yeah and
that is at the heart of literal like um
that's the that's the class position
that many people have uh it's very
important in like the civil rights
movement in America is very important in
like uh you know uh the the
Reconstruction Era politics in America
in the aftermath of the abolition of
slavery where like uh you know newly
free newly freed uh black people
um started recognizing that they had
exactly the same class position as the
Layman the people that were Wade slaves
right right
um and and um that that wage slaves yeah
it's like what it's considered I think
like originally in the Republican party
uh In America which is now very
different Republican party started off
with uh wanting to abolish slavery
um you know Shadow slavery in the South
and Wade slavery in the North like that
was their Credo right
um so uh but basically no I mean I don't
even heard that online if people did
saying derogatory those people here just
work normal jobs
you're a wage slave well yeah they they
use it as a as a derogatory term but
um but yeah that's it's that's at the
heart of like class politics so there's
no way that dude wrote that on accident
no no for sure fit into that and video
Saga was very I try to keep very anime
but does go ahead tell me it's not
political
super political yeah I mean okay so when
you say it's political do you think
there is a do you think it's just
exploring political ideas or do you
think there's uh are you saying that
there's an agenda that he's trying to
like portray in this story I don't think
it's nefarious I think that people have
World Views yeah that they inevitably
bake into their art you know what I mean
and I think like his world view from
what you've told me especially like he's
like a pacifist humanitarian yeah yeah I
mean
um he I mean for once I actually have a
source because I talk to the [__]
I'm not making this a [__] up yeah no he
uh he said the reason he wanted to make
villain Saga is that he wanted he
thought it won he thought it was an
interesting interesting idea for a story
to agree to have a story about violence
and promoting how you know bad war and
violence is and setting that in the
Viking era why did he make it so cool
um that's the problem season one is so
bad at yeah yeah and then season two
feels like such a departure yeah in a
sense of like when is that gonna happen
yeah every time I see that log throwing
Guy what's the big one uh every time I
see him I'm like oh thank God all right
let's get let's get some violence in
here
yeah and like he was he he told me that
he was very very worried going into like
part two uh because in order to
establish the you know this message he
needed to establish a world where it was
violence was glorified and then what he
wanted to do was establish his world of
glorified violence and kind of break
down why you know why that's bad and why
would you see another angle to that and
uh one of his biggest worries is that he
did a bit of a bit too good of a job
with that because everyone because
everyone really really loved the first
part yeah just definitely went over a
lot of people's hands yeah yeah I
thought the message was like violence is
sick that's what I thought
it's okay if you're Welsh yeah yeah yeah
as long as you're a viking it's okay
yeah yeah you love that he's like the
best Welsh representation ever it's the
only representation we got in here yeah
yeah exactly so sick you know you know
what he called you know what he called
askalad you said cute right he said cute
he said he said he said ask lad was my
favorite character even though it was
like very hard for him to pick yeah and
I was like oh why'd you like ask her
that and he was like oh Kawaii and I was
like what I mean he is cute he's a cute
[__] he is
I see it yeah but yeah I mean like I I
asked him where did you get your
inspiration for your story are you
trying to say anything you know are you
trying to how did you get the ideas for
what you wanted to portray in this story
um and he basically just said I just I
sometimes I just have thoughts and ideas
and emotions that I want to convey
through the story and I find the best
way uh with characters and with the
world to basically convey my thoughts
and emotions and so I don't know how
deeply he thinks into the political
ideas but I think at the core he has
these emotions
um that he wants to put on the page and
so um oh yeah finds the best way to get
the moving parts to like portray that I
don't even think he's like ideologically
marks is there anything like that I just
uh I think it's like very human to
recognize that Injustice yeah yeah so so
it totally still makes sense but I mean
it's at the heart of that kind of
politics right yeah I think I think
talking to him he is a very human like
article he's tries to to tell very human
stories and he tries to put that in
everything he does well I would argue
that's what makes some of the best
stories in Manga and Anime right it's
like when you're trying to show that
like very Human Side of like you know
through emotions and you know uh
physical violence and stuff like that
it's like oh okay it's not just like a
bunch of people killing each other
there's like yeah some message there and
you know depending on who you ask you
know they get the message more than
others obviously Hassan has like [__]
nailed it but I love it yeah yeah but
like I think it's I think some of the
best authors uh especially in the manga
world are able to kind of you know try
and show both sides of aware it's like
you can think of it as shallowly as
possible or as deeply as possible and
it's still just as enjoyable I want more
historical manga anime I feel like it's
hard though because I know it's hard but
it's so cool when they do it the amount
of research that he has to go through
just to write like a single chapter is
[__] insane yeah he has he has to do
so much research because what what uh
how many how many how much Viking media
did we get here in Japan like nothing
that's nothing that's what's fascinating
about it because it's like such a unique
time period uh like Dane law and the
invasion of like England is is so cool
and there's a lot of content in the
western world yeah but it it pairs very
nicely with like the last Kingdom and
and other kinds of like Western live
action like docu dramas you know what I
mean like fictionalized depictions of
what happened so it works really well
with that yeah and I think I think
what's most impressive is that he's done
his research and he's taken like real
historical accounts like you know Thor
Thor Kell
um thorofin they were all like real
actually I don't know if Thor's was a
real character but Thor uh thorofin was
definitely a real person in history
right yeah and so you he takes these
accounts of real things that happen in
histories uh and he's kind of like
filled in the blanks with his own
imagination or even his even Dorman's
Granddad or I guess is technically is
that his grandfather like the guy who
went to oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
that's really personal really awesome
yeah yeah the first person who like
actually found well found America
if you want to get spoilers just read
the Wikipedia page
I read all the manga was at the time
extended edition of the manga yeah it's
like that that's extra law that's the
light novel that's what I love about
historical shows is that if you want
more you can just go to Wikipedia like
you can you can look in and around where
they tell the story kind of be like oh
this is fun yeah like I don't want to
wait for the manga to come out I'm just
going to read the Wikipedia page
is why they stop at a certain point
because it just the stories often just
go downhill because history can't always
be interesting or the person's weird
yeah they become really strange or do
weird [__] up stuff yeah yeah well you
know sometimes they still take weird
characters like in Jojo and uh present
them in a Shining Light
oh God go on you can say it what
the Nazi
oh okay that one okay that was like I
was not expecting that when I was
watching because I'm like I'm like wow
this like new anime I got into is like
so sick I'm like burning through the
episodes and then bam I'm like what did
I just see a swastika what the [__] like
and then and then I'm like okay like
this is clearly a villain right and then
and then at the end it's like oh no he's
like a good guy and you think like oh
he's gonna like be a Nazi killer right
and then he's like no he died in Germany
in World War II fighting fighting for
the Nazis
like they put that in there I was like I
think I wiped that from him yeah I
completely forgot about that that's like
such an insane thing that they put in
there that you just don't have to put in
but he did it anyway and I was like wow
well this is this is untainted by
Western liberal hegemonic attitudes I'll
tell you that okay wait I go to Austin
you've have you finished part six no oh
I wanted him to get to it yeah I'm gonna
I'm going to message you when you finish
politics because there is a point in
part six where they tackle the topic of
racism in America
oh that's my favorite yeah
and I I want to hear your takes on that
oh that's so sick I love that yeah
clearly it's near the end of part six so
yeah we'll we'll continue this
conversation I love yeah I love when
like you know Japanese people are like
yeah let's let's cover American races
yeah like out of nowhere like what no
I'm fascinated by like the perspective
of someone that's like super far removed
from you know like the actual history or
the culture like there's not it's not
like there's a lot of black people in
Japan you know what I mean I grew up in
Turkey not a lot of like uh afro Turks
in turkey that's not like a real thing
it's like very marginal very small
amount yeah so uh you know I was
fascinated by by Black Culture in
America so I I kind of get how that
works on this part of the world because
like a lot of American cultures is Black
Culture for the most part it's just like
so a lot of the popular depictions of
American culture is literally uh usually
Black Culture yeah
um and and so I I love I love seeing
other people also go through that
speaking of black culture and Anime
actually one of the reasons why one of
the reasons why I love Samurai shampoo
is because like it kind of merges like
oh yeah
K-pop stuff yeah it's like it's so weird
that you know before Samurai Champloo
you know the idea of merging samurais
with hip-hop was just so out of left
field and now it just like it's like the
perfect glove that fits yeah like how
would how did no one think of this
before as well yeah why does it work so
well I still have no idea there were
some other ones too have you guys ever
seen Afro Samurai yeah hell yeah that's
Samuel Johnson Samuel Jackson that's
sick I would even go somewhere say like
Boondocks is also like weirdly drawn
exactly in the anime style I don't know
why but like it's one of my favorite I
wouldn't say animes I guess I don't know
it's like anime inspired cartoon yeah
yeah I think one of the co-creators
LaShawn Thomas is like he's a huge anime
yeah yeah to the point where he's made
some some of his own original animation
yeah as well so it's no surprise that it
was probably heavily inspired yeah no
it's it's that that I I love because
like I when I was in Turkey I was like
watching the [__] out of that I love
Aaron Magruder he's brilliant really
really clever
um and you know so there is this like
very cool merger of two cultures uh in
that respect yeah absolutely I mean it's
kind of like like as like you said a lot
of there's a lot of fascination with you
know the Western World and especially
the American culture here in Japan and
you know oh I've seen it oh yeah yeah
not even in anime man in just everything
but I'm like that too I'm a Marabou so
like yeah so like that's what that
that's what I was I think they're called
Wester booze yeah yeah the British one's
called tiaboo
yeah who the [__] is booing the British
culture
the British
Vlog the British vlogger Invasion yeah
like literally just 10 years ago on the
internet being British was like the
coolest thing ever okay I got on it I
guess I erased after my memory because
like thank God
the era for a second yeah that was that
was like there was an era of British uh
culture where every American thought it
was cool you know because because of
Mostly because of like Harry Potter
actually yeah back back when that was
yeah no Americans like a good chunk of
Americans still think like that's
England is Hogwarts yeah like they think
it's real you know yeah it's just an
entire country ruin my fantasy I mean a
lot of Japanese people think that way as
well oh yeah yeah oh no I've been to
Harajuku I know I know what Japanese
people think America looks like right
now it's like they they were trying to
sell me like Yankee sweaters and [__]
I'm like no man I'm good how has it been
being possibly the biggest person in
Japan right now it's so [__] sad dude
it's so because like I I grew up being
fascinated by like Japanese fashion
thinking like you know Japanese garments
like the the history of it you know post
World War II like raw denim all this
stuff right and and I finally come to
Japan and I'm I guess weebing out a
little bit yeah and I go to like
Harajuku and I see everyone is so
dripped out there's dress so well and
then I'm like I'm touching the clothes
but I can't wear them every store I went
to they made fun of me they laughed at
me
I walk into the store I walk into the
store and I go what's the largest size
you have just in general yeah it goes
medium like [__] that means in
the middle like there's got to be more
sizes after medium and the thing is
that's a Japanese Medium as well it's
probably a small American small yeah
yeah it's like bro you guys love
American culture but for some reason you
don't have anything fitting American
sizes yeah yeah I went to I went to Jean
Street and I have like a western sized
ass I guess yeah and it was impossible
to get anything that fit so I got one
that fit but the legs were like this
long extra because they thought that
like to oh yeah and then I had to tell
them can you please like cut it please
but it's really nice denim though yeah
but he's just rubbing any of his faces
yeah yeah I know well I had the opposite
problem yeah so I want like you have
sick pants okay you guys can't see but
he's wearing like super cool like kind
of parachute pants yeah right yeah and
they're all the rage and I want to buy
one I finally after a long day of
getting owned everywhere I went I I'm
about to call my Uber taxi yeah okay and
then I see see a beams plus I walk in
there's a fat guy okay immediately I
rushed to him he's the first fat retail
guy I've seen okay in Japan I'm like bro
please help me I'm like please uh and he
looked at me and he knew immediately
what my problem was yeah I got you and
um you know he brought out like a bunch
of these like pants and I put it on the
first one is like kind of tight but it's
fine it but it's a little bit short okay
I'm like okay well this is fitted anyway
like it's not supposed to be but it's
fitted on me and then I finally see this
parachute pants I put them on they're
[__] capris on me dude they're
supposed to go down to your foot they
were like above my they were above my
ankles yes I have the opposite problem
my race show like ass to leg ratio is
like all [__] up and you have the
opposite end of that yeah well yeah
because like he I mean he was so happy
that he like found some stuff for me and
I put it on and I was just like now it's
too short I failed you I'm sorry you're
tall and you're massive as well yeah so
it's like it's either one or the other
that you can get here in Japan yeah yeah
the arm length is like really terrible
too yeah everybody Wears Like oversized
stuff now so that's cool like at least I
can like find things that fit usually
right but like I'll put on a I just want
a [__] trench coat like everyone in
Japan they love wearing those long
trench coats yeah they kind of look like
normal jackets on me which is fine
I'll still wear it every time I wear a
trench go the arm comes to here I'm like
no shot like it's just here can't do it
it's only a real life backy character
yeah yeah it sucks you've watched Bucky
right yeah yeah have you is there any
political messages in Becky that I
didn't realize dude Baki is just insane
there's no
I mean I told you about uh uh I think
like well Che Guevara is like literally
in the show as long as in the manga I
know like Donald Trump is in the manga
yeah yeah it's super political yeah like
uh it's like a whole like Muhammad Ali
uh yeah there's that too goes to meet
Barack Obama yeah yeah yeah
political one yeah there's a lot of that
but like but even then it's like there's
no like consistent political message no
no at all there's no consistent anything
yeah
because he he thought it was yeah yeah
no that that makes sense to me because I
love that like it's so sick because uh
every time I re-watch it like whenever
I'm in the gym when I'm working out I'm
thinking I'm him yeah like I'm literally
like yeah like [__] push through this
so can I you know what I mean just have
to have sex to power up real quick
it's the most psychotic thing I've ever
seen he's just like yeah
yeah beat it up son
I don't know how he he did this but
somehow he tries and almost manages to
frame it as like something epic yeah
which is weird because it is
yeah when the father goes you need to
[__] [__] every day and I'm like damn I
need to get out and [__] dude he's
gonna solve Japan's birthday by himself
man holy [__] oh my God yeah could never
isn't that a thing I thought he like
didn't like the hikomores and the weebs
and [__] because like they all they do
is like watch hentai instead of [__]
that's what I've heard boys shut the
hell up for a second because this
episode is sponsored by vessi look at my
kicks right here you see these beautiful
shoes these are a pair of verses and let
me tell you why these are currently my
favorite pair of shoes to wear these are
100 waterproof which is great for the
unpredictable Spring weather look at me
walking in these in some snow that's
some real genuine snow right there not a
single drop getting into my socks boys
not only that but they're comfortable
durable and breathable and I personally
got myself these slip-on ones you don't
have to deal with any laces you can just
slip them right on and my favorite part
of this is is that they're made from
dime attacks that's a dual climate knit
material that keeps you cool in the
summer and warm in Colder Weather so you
can rock these kicks literally 365 days
a year so if you're gonna go outside and
touch grass then why not get yourself a
comfortable pair of shoes to boot grab
yourself a pair of vessels by going to
vesi.com trash taste they have a ton of
different styles and sizes for every
single person and if you use our coupon
code trash taste at check out you can
get 15 off your entire order and if you
live in these countries you can get
yourself some free shipping as well so
make sure to click the link in the
description below or go to vesi.com
trash taste to get yourself the only
pair of shoes you will ever need hey
boys and girls I hope you're having a
good day because today's episode is
sponsored by betterhelp you know a lot
of us can feel like we're going through
confusing times recently life is
changing we're growing sometimes we
don't even know what we want or who we
are like to think I'm an open person but
there have been times in my life where
there have been some things where I felt
a bit reserved or maybe even a bit
embarrassed to talk about which is why I
turn to talk therapy at one point
there's a lot of preconceptions about
what talk therapy is and who actually
needs it but at the end of the day it
kind of just deepens my understanding of
myself at a time when I felt a little
bit more confused and lost and that's
when a service like better help could
come in really useful it helped connects
you to a licensed therapist that can
help you on your journey of
self-discovery from wherever you are you
know one thing I've really appreciated
about a service like this is one of the
most daunting things about about getting
into talk therapy is taking that time
and going out your way to find someone
who's suitable for you and this removes
that barrier entirely it's designed to
be flexible and convenient suiting your
schedule whenever you want to do it and
if you're just not feeling it that's
fine as well you can switch therapists
at any time for no additional costs so
if you want to give it a go discover
your potential today with better help
visit betterhelp.com trash to get 10 off
your first month that's better help
help.com trash to get 10 off your first
month thank you very much better health
for sponsoring this episode back to the
video so what other anime takes you have
yeah I'm invested he told me this
garbage one time okay okay this one this
one's a spicy one okay so a lot of
people have opinions on Attack on Titan
uh on like whether it's fascists or
Communists I don't care uh about that I
like Attack on Titan a lot I think it's
very interesting
it's the only I'm not a big fan of this
genre but it's the only Mecca anime I
watch Attack on Titan is a mecha anime
let's discuss what is there to discuss
there's nothing to discuss it's just you
know you know what no he's right no
don't don't he's all right
okay okay question question is [__]
Ratatouille maca
technically technically it could be okay
technically it could be but if if aot is
not Mecca then what about Eva Evas
see I
there's a popular organic they're aliens
okay second of all like I I don't know
Ava for me is really weird because it's
like at first glance it tries to present
itself as a Mecca yeah but then the
further you go along you realize it's
not a Mecca it's just a [__] sci-fi
you are controlling a flesh Mega in
almost an identical way uh that you
would control an Eva literally literally
originally comes from there is a
separate mechanical thing yeah that a
person goes into that they control to
become part of them
Attack on Titan they are the Americas
because you're Japanese what what do
they call this genre in Japanese because
Mech is like a mechanical it's from an
English word what do they call it in
Japan Mega yeah Mecca as well yeah Mecca
oh sure yeah it's from like a mechanical
term yeah yeah it literally it's talking
about things like you know Gundam and
like yeah
like you know like some human going into
a robot that is there before they go
into it yeah right then they're just
taking English so [__] Maybe
yeah
I know a lot of Mecca fans get so pissed
off at this argument yeah dude whenever
I talk about this like I'm like I'm no
fan of Mecha anime except for aot people
go what how dare you say that but it
like it makes sense just think about it
fans Rejoice Mecca is not dead
you don't really care for the boundaries
of what isn't what genre yeah because I
I wish I guess you know I feel like this
is how you're gonna this is you're gonna
come to terms with the argument by
saying it sucks but like whatever
extend the definition of Mecca to
include that that's why I say flesh
Mecca yeah yeah because like if you if
you don't think Attack on Titan is a
Mecca then Ava's not a Mecca in my
opinion because it's all organic
material
um you know that the mechs that they
pilot uh are you know real organic
beings and they are this that's if you
never watch it you've watched David I
watched it don't miss that part
it is it does get very confusing
19 plot twists back to back but they
mentioned that during the not confusing
part oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
might have just forgotten kind of like a
pretty I probably just thought there's a
robot dude like a fundamental part of
the whole thing do not remember where
the robot goes berserk
um oh yeah I remember that and then the
armor like falls off yeah oh I cannot
remember this yeah yeah so I just I just
thought they were still robots yeah okay
well in that convention right a Mecca
could basically be like some person
controlling something
yeah kind of yeah so would you say vtube
is a Mech isn't it
here's where I think here's what I think
the difference between like a Mech and
Attack on Titan is right like if you if
you picked up a sword and started using
it yeah right it's not the same as if
you [__] spouted out a sword from
your arm like your arm just turned it
like transformed into us right right
it's fundamentally different right
because you're you're having this use
the blade and wield it right I think the
fact that you can get out of it like the
fact that you can get out of it
afterwards like I think that like makes
it that solidifies it for me as like a
Mecca because I know what I mean like if
we're going to talk about control
systems and Mecca there are so many
different control systems in like Mecca
when it comes to either just you know
mechanical controls or you know
something more kin to Ava and in the
case of Attack on Titan it's like we we
can argue that the control system is
just them becoming the body are we
really gonna go down this round of like
creating subgenres yeah [__] arguments
oh my the umbrella term is Mecca but
this is the
I think that it fits it fits the the
same like style also very political
apparently yeah just like all the other
Mecca animes are from what I understand
yeah it is yeah yeah yeah
like has no one ever like presented this
to the to the mangaka no one wants to
hear it I just like because
people get mad but like searching for
who Hassan who asked yeah well I don't
know I'm Africa cast I think he just
wanted to make a cool story yeah but uh
yeah I I'm asking when it's gonna end
that's what I'm asking well we're on
final season part three hopefully yeah
so hopefully next year is I'm I'm hoping
I'd hope I'm hoping I don't know man
there's not even that much material left
in the monks dude they're gonna milk the
[__] out of the Milky like as if they
haven't already I mean like yeah I I I
I'm I said it was going to be this year
but it's gonna be nice it's not gonna be
nice yeah guys I'm saying it now it's
gonna be next year there's only so many
chapters left there's not that many
chapters left so unless they they go an
original route and go something
completely different from the manga then
it's going to be there's not that much
material does that happen often I don't
know not So Much Anymore it used to be a
way more popular thing to kind of uh
take what was in the manga and a lot of
times the manga wasn't finished so they
just make their own original ending I
mean Akira did that yeah Kira did that
yeah Metal Alchemist did that even
though I haven't actually seen the
original Fullmetal alchemistry full
metal Alchemists yeah yeah the original
Trigon did that as well actually I think
uh Fullmetal Alchemist the newer version
is better than this
yeah that's common yeah that's the
common yeah I've watched it like I've
watched both
Jesus
you're coming to terms with some of the
things I'm saying I feel like I'm
putting it down because Brotherhood it's
not coming I'm putting it down and
you're picking it up okay what other
[__] takes do you have what else do I
have I have like notes okay
oh my God I was prepared I guess there's
ever been on trash days yeah yeah no I
mean I I uh most of it I used up already
yeah yeah
um no I have like I mean I have one
where I just like I call it the Zelda
principle this one's like spicy where I
feel like Zelda which is not an anime
but it's still like still you know
Japanese art video games yeah where I
feel like Zelda doesn't have to be 17
but they say she is and it's like that's
one thing where I'm just like but why
did you say she's 17 like they say it
like multiple times throughout the game
they're like they're like but know that
she's 17 I'm like well you didn't draw
her like that
like what why do you have to like you
just say she's 18. it's fine it's the
same age range you know what I mean yeah
I mean I hate this stuff too have you
ever watched uh Tokyo uh revenges no
it's about like biker gangs and they
beat and uh kill each other uh but that
full team
well and then you have JoJo which is
like yeah which which is hilarious
because like no one even thinks that
they're 15 and it's almost like a joke
it's like a self-referential joke where
it's like cool he'll just be like I'm 15
by the way and he's like built like a 35
year old man who's like taking steroids
of the past tense Bucky that's the same
thing right now I'm a cold is 15 but
he's like [__] tatted up like or
scars everything in part three yeah he's
17. yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and they
and they point to it and you're like
okay well that's just silly like I just
I I feel like at that point you almost
just disregard the age because like the
age is obviously just [__] yeah of
course like because the car like what do
you take more because online there's
always this discussion of but the
characters this age it's like well if
you're we're talking personality and
lock some of the character determine
more of the the age or is it purely
whatever the guy says it is yeah no you
got dudes with like full facial hair and
they're like yo I'm I'm 17 by the way
make sure you understand I'm 17 I'm like
no you're not what the [__] are you
doing
I think it was weird you would not get
carded yeah
is when you have someone that looks like
that
um you know you know you could say
they're 50 and it's like a joke whatever
but when it's like you have something
like that and then they put them in high
school it's just like there is no
[__] way this guy is in high school
that's what I loved about the beginning
of part three when Joe Tara goes back to
school
how are you in high school right it's
like six seven and it's just like yeah
blending
he's just so jacked and so much bigger
than everyone else
[Laughter]
it's [__] up yeah
it's like oh man all these assassins are
coming and trying to kill him in high
school
it's weird so what would you say you
anime taste uh what kind of like anime
do you actually like
like what kind of anime do you gravitate
towards I think like I watched a lot of
Shonen obviously like which is part of
the reason why I think the characters
are supposed to be teenage because like
yeah there are people for teenagers
mainly yeah um but I mean that and and I
guess like
I I know what I don't like and it's just
like romance stuff or like cute [__]
like I'm not into any of that yeah at
all that's fair are you into like
heavily political stuff not as in like
exploring like different political ideas
no not even like I I don't I get excited
when I see something that I that I
recognize as like political within the
anime yeah but it's not something I like
seek out at all right like I've never
watched uh what's it called Code Geass
um yes no I've never watched it and
everyone says well is it it's Mecca
right yeah
yeah and I don't like Mecha anime but
like from what I understand all the
mecca animes are like literally the most
like yeah
I think the original I think it's maybe
Gundam
um that that's like straight up written
by communist like no no like an actual
like I think Communist Party communist
if I'm not mistaken really I don't wanna
yeah I don't want to say the wrong thing
maybe maybe that's [__] chicken no no
it's like what is it called like legend
of the galactic heroes maybe is it that
way no no no no no no yeah it's like
it's like snake something maybe what is
it
seed
maybe the original Gundam the original
Gundam is just Gundam yeah yeah maybe I
don't know I'll look it up
yeah yeah like one of the one of the
first ever like uh Gundams ever created
was like straight up I think made by
like a like a communist card carrying
you know Japanese Communist Party member
oh wow yeah so like Gundam Gundams do
have a history of like being very
political
yeah I mean yeah most meccas are except
for like the Super Robot kind of like
genre most meccas are heavily steeped in
you know different political ideas most
likely inspired from shows like Gundam
right yeah yeah exactly I mean Gundam
started the real Mecca kind of genre and
a lot of them kind of like similar to
attack on Titan you know where there's a
lot of politics and Attack on Titans
right yes you'd love code chaos yeah I
mean I'll we'll see I just we'll see I
know you'll never guess the art style is
like really important to me too and I
when I see like um the old school like
very big face uh our style like it just
I can't guess
I've said so many things except for old
school and I would have accepted that
it's not it's not that it's old school
but like it does kind of have that like
like unique look right yeah yeah yeah I
would say because wait but hold on you
sat through Baki
can't get more unique than that that
looks like the ugliest anime yeah yeah
but it's so beautiful
I love I just I love like it's the same
like Jojo it's like just muscular
behemoths you know it's so sick because
we need more of that anime yeah I love
it no me too if you love that then you
should watch first of the North Star
this is oh I've heard about that one
yeah that is definitely awesome yeah
yeah that is kind of like I think what
you know did this Northstar come before
Jojo I think it did yeah yeah it did
yeah
oh okay yeah
that's a really classic anime do you
watch old anime at all because I feel
like a lot of people now if it gets past
a certain point where it becomes like
hand drawn anime a lot of people aren't
interested I love hand-drawn though I do
I do like hand-drawn anime too but yeah
it's uh it depends it totally depends
like sometimes it's harder to get into I
mean I look I I watched all of the old
one-piece episodes you know what I mean
yeah like and and it was definitely like
significantly slower in the beginning
too oh yeah so we're going for more like
Saturday morning cartoons yeah like
telling a serious story yeah so I think
a lot of filler as well
yeah the website's dedicated to letting
you skip oh I I use that like I use the
pace I have the I don't use one page
because I I don't want to download it
because like it's too much work
um but I use like the filler anime uh
website this animes to tell you we're
trying to uh yeah yeah it's so it's so
clutch because like I mean I can even
tell sometimes when it's like very
clearly filler oh yeah yeah yeah like
especially when they don't feature like
any of the main characters oh yeah yeah
you're just like why did you make this
episode Hunter Hunter
is too long
that's a that's a commentary okay
okay that was like you're just so mad at
me when I say this well a lot of people
like the camera around I don't know I
like it it's great yeah but like if you
if you literally just look at the
episodes or chapters comparatively it is
like more than everything else combined
before it yeah
um because it's like what 80 episodes in
the anime yeah it's it's like it's like
it's like half the anime I feel like and
the anime is 144 or something and it's
it's most of it yeah and it's long it is
long and I think the first part of the
camaron arc was a little bit slow a
little bit slow and then and then Hunter
Hunter greatest pedophile villain of all
time
people will go online to defend a
pedophile if he's kind of cool yeah yeah
yeah they shouldn't have made him so
cool
because he's like he's like the
strongest guy yeah they should have been
like that's a bad guy and he's weak yeah
he's like literally the most like the
strongest mysterious character in the
show I feel like lasers they really
limit tested that because they're you
know his psycho's always been like a
creepy character right and then there's
the scene where he literally says I'm
getting an erection right yeah and it's
just like okay okay I don't know if
that's limit testing at that point they
broke through
like that yeah they're like okay can you
distill your minds after this scene it's
insane and jump looked at them was like
yeah publish it let's go one of the most
epic fights in the manga yeah is uh
between uh what's his name
and uh hisoka yeah they fight in the
manga and it's like insane it's like the
most insane fight if you can get through
his really bad manga drawings oh yeah oh
well they well he usually repatches it
for the actual volumes yeah he would
it's been canceled now so oh really yeah
so it's not happening anymore but um uh
he did not because of the pedophile
[Music]
does in the series
that doesn't get you canceled yeah
um we gotta finish it dude over
completion is his his drawings were like
so bad uh it's because he had a
seriously
at that point you're like just just wait
just just hold up why don't they like
you can't have someone else like try to
recreate it don't Marcus also have like
you know apprentices yeah they do but
Togashi is like known as like a super
perfectionist like yeah I think during
you hawk show he didn't have a single
assistant my teacher all that himself
but like I mean overworked to death oh
yeah yeah he's been going through some
bad health and that's been like pretty
well known so I mean
yeah yeah yeah I mean we were
unfortunate yeah I mean I think after
what happened to uh contara Miura like
berserk's author yeah yeah I think the
every every manka is like oh this is a
thing that can happen now yeah I better
look after myself and I think luckily I
think after that fans are a lot more
understanding about I finally have an
excuse to actually start hunt Hunter now
now that I know it's not coming down
finally so finally I can start reading
it yeah I feel like just like some of
the most iconic facts in anime are in
Hunter Hunter there's just so many bang
of fights that uh don't drag on too long
also political you got Health Care
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
okay break that down for me the [__]
what's the guy I deserve so long since I
watched it but the main guy oh yeah
why is he even involved
why is he involved because he wants to
[__] pay for health care
it's true
like well you just see Healthcare like
that's about me no I'm just saying that
but that's literally why he wants to do
because he's like he needs to pay for
healthcare and then uh Healthcare
another odor reference back to [__]
uh the snow Island whichever whatever
yeah yeah yeah that's it yeah drum
island is literally about paywalling
Healthcare
[__]
arrest every doctor and he's like I'm
gonna control the health care now you
may not like it but this is what the US
will be like in two years
how do you watch that and not realize
that
[Applause]
I thought like oh the doctors it ain't
that deep Bro
I felt like it wasn't that deep no it
100 is that no no it is not that I will
ride dude I hope I hope Odo watches your
podcast dude
Okay the reason I don't think is it's
that deep is because most the world
don't really think about healthcare
because it's nice inherently in America
yeah
he sees how bad it is he's like drum
island is very similar to America
you got the magical witch at the top
yeah
[Music]
dude that's another crazy thing for me
with one piece is like
I don't know what is going on with like
the way women are drawn and now I'm on
Amazon really I'm on the the Amazon Lily
like Arc now so it's like this is the
first time I've seen versatility because
Oda either draws women like the most
busted you've ever seen or the just the
same hot uh like super sexy type yeah
yeah definitely and I I you know I want
to talk about too much uh but uh yeah
one problem I've had is figuring out who
is Nami yeah he's in the manga it's
there's no colors yeah yeah some some
frames it's genuine oh yeah like you
have to double take I think obviously I
think he gets better I think well I
can't speak of the manga but like the
the anime definitely starts getting a
little bit better it would like
distinguishing the characters
you see the color
yeah there's some frames you generally
have to sit there for like 20 seconds oh
yeah okay you just gotta you have to
figure out like he he puts different
hairstyles yeah but like slightly
sometimes yeah well I say also the time
skip right it gets a little bit better
so you think I have not seen it I know
this is not there yet
I know how scared you go you're about I
wasn't gonna go in just in case yeah
just in case anything I know it's gonna
happen I thought wow I'm 500 chapters in
and still hasn't happened okay how the
[__] are you in Japan and like don't get
it spoiled all the time okay no I do but
there's so much [__] there's so much
one-piece stuff it is impossible to
piece anything together okay I go to the
gym [__] watching it all on the
treadmills I don't I I cannot Escape
it's awesome but there's so much one
piece that like you almost you have no
idea when [__] is gonna happen yeah and
because like
weirdest like the art style is so weird
yeah certain characters happen uh have
these Transformations and it means
nothing until I kind of have some
context that's one thing I love about
one piece is that they change outfits a
little bit yeah yeah which I think is so
sick I wish other anime do that yes and
I wish more anime did do that because it
makes them feel more like people killer
has dripping Hunter Hunter he's always
changing oh yeah everything like
everything
um Takashi draws they they have drips
drip right drip yeah also bleach bleach
bleach bleach I would say pioneered the
anime I think so I think so JoJo is
literally permanently stuck on like
catwalk fashion yeah yeah
JoJo's Beyond JoJo takes it a different
level yeah yeah
but like especially like with one piece
even when I started it I got spoiled
with some of One Piece because of like
you'd you'd like go on like social media
you'd see some fan art or someone had uh
Avatar and you go walking in in like
Akihabara and there's a figure there
yeah that's what happened to me I bought
a Zorro figure and he doesn't have an
eye I'm like oh [__] like
I'm like come on man
or like I mean I'm sure you've seen like
Luffy with the chest thing like yeah
I've seen I've seen so many yeah goofy
looking like Popeye yeah it means
I'm just gonna have to like the thing is
it's like it's kind of it's kind of like
Jojo it's like if I tell you like part
seven Jesus Christ is in it it's like
yeah it gives you [__] nothing yeah
it's so stupid and so out there that it
doesn't mean much until it's actually in
context yeah yeah I tell you X character
dies that's a spoiler right yeah yeah
you'll agree yeah but if you see a
picture of a character looking [__]
weird yeah you pretty much only realize
that you were spoiled the moment it
happens in the show yeah and at that
point you've already yeah it's already
got to the point yeah it really doesn't
you're just waiting for it to come at
that point right yeah yeah exactly like
I
um for me it was like gear second I I
knew that was coming somewhere in like
the one piece future yeah
um and I was like I don't know what gear
second is people online keep saying gear
second uh do they get a car or something
I have no [__] clue yeah uh then it
happens and it just like it didn't ruin
it for me because I'm like oh it's so
hot this is it and this is [__] this
is why everyone was talking about it
yeah okay I just I just I wish Luffy was
a little less goofy though like that I
don't know I I guess I'm alone in that
tag everyone always yells about that too
I just I wish it was like because like
Zorro is so [__] cool dude I [__]
love Zorro
that's the Samurai Champloo fan and
you've seen that yeah right yeah so but
he is sick he's so funny is my favorite
yeah John's the kind of character that
only works in anime and like real life
if you if someone acted like Zara you'd
be like bro what is wrong with you just
talk yeah well also like even even down
to the sleeping all the time like
no that's like so anime but he's it's
such a sick character yeah even though
apparently what what is the meme people
say he's a racist
well he only fights like black and brown
people he literally no literally and
also and also Oda said that uh he would
be a cop in the real world which is kind
of sad but but whatever like she's still
so sick I've seen compilations
every one of his enemies are black and
brown every single one
I gotta go back through okay yeah I
gotta go back through it surprisingly
also one piece like definitely the most
diverse anime
uh I will say that if you've gone that
long it'll just happen I think yeah I
think naturally yeah oda's just learned
that like oh diversity is a thing and
it's just like yeah okay yeah I mean I I
think uh you know part of the reason
that I mean I mean Luffy is like
supposed to be Brazilian right yeah
I bet you don't know I I think Luffy's
his own Enigma
definitely is usop definitely is like I
believe I think it's black yeah they did
say at one point I'm sure I've seen this
on Twitter it's Twitter just they have
yeah they have like nationalities I
think and and zoro's Japanese and and
you know Frankie's American like that
sort of thing and I don't know if that's
like added on as like a style it does
make sense though especially because
well you've seen you you were at you
finished Water Seven yes okay so you've
seen Frankie yes yeah okay like he's an
arms manufacturer like he literally is
like I need to know that you didn't even
tell me that Frankie was American yeah
yeah I mean he gets powered by Coke yeah
like what the [__] he's super like I'm
cool that's like that's like a
deliberate choice so for sure he's like
he's like a weapons manufacturer slash
like yeah
and is a is a rockabilly which is like
you know very Japanese to like hyper
focus on rockabilly aesthetic I love
that [__] yeah um have you ever seen any
anime or Manga do like diversity or
politics terrible you're like oh God no
uh was it
okay
where like Simon there's a there's a
black sushi
bro like that's gotta be racist like I
saw that I was like what the [__]
what are you doing are you doing
that was like yo that ain't him like
what the [__] did you do that you've
never seen a black person
I remember that I remember seeing that I
was like okay that's like that's a bit
much damn that's like in my head it's
like way worse examples yeah 21 yeah I
think uh ants is probably the one oh
dance yeah but that's only that's only
in the manga that's only in the market
yeah
wait wait what happens I want to know
[Music]
it's so absurd that if I say it I feel
like I must have misremembered it
because there's no way it can be that
bad wait really what the [__] so he
wants to get framed for a shooting right
yes a public shooting because God's is
extremely edgy it's it's you know it's
like extremely edgy there's a lot of
violence and Gore and it's great at
certain points but this part is
definitely [__] awful yeah it's kind
of like a really [__] up death game uh
where they put a bunch of contestants uh
into a round place in Japan and they
have to kill a bunch of aliens are the
aliens like super opium everyone dies
all the time yeah uh so that's kind of
like the series we're talking about I
can't remember why this character does
it I think something is trying to frame
someone she does a public shooting but
so bad and then to disguise himself uh
so that the people that put him as him
he disguises himself as like a black man
and it's so bad it's so bad and the way
they draw it is just terrible
oh that's so bad did like menstrual [__]
it's bad it's so bad oh I gotta I gotta
juice I don't have my phone on me right
now
like I love [__] like that
why because it's fascinating to me
yeah it's like it's like insane that
like this guy thought like this is I
found it yeah oh he's just black face oh
that's like tasteful yeah but that's
like a it's a Japanese dude yeah no no
no I understand I I thought it was gonna
be worse it was so better if it's like I
think
what the [__] that one's funny what the
[__] is oh yeah
yeah
um that is yeah that yeah that's the
that's the frame though yeah that's
right it's so bad dude it's pretty bad
that's not as bad as I thought it was
gonna be well it's just it's just the
notion I thought it was like gonna
disguise myself I thought it was gonna
be straight up menstrual [__] like you
know [__] yeah old depictions like
old-timey depictions yeah Americans can
get way more racist about black people
than Japanese people no I know something
about it an anime that feels so weird
and out of pocket yeah because it's like
whoa there's something about it that
feels uneducated about it right where
it's like they just maybe
that's why bakkie is the best at black
representation like biscuit all of us is
the goat yeah he's the guy who runs the
prison yeah
yeah very just fundamentally weird
attitude about how American carceral
structure works but is that how it works
yeah yeah you get the the biggest guy
eats everyone else
yeah I mean but I think a lot of it just
comes down to just exposure you know
yeah they don't have the same exposure
this the same conversations yeah all the
same a lot of the same issues you know
that America's going through so it's
just which is why it was a different
lens odor is the goat and is like very
clearly anti-racist literally entire
slavery Arc I'm not gonna get too deep
into it okay every anime has a slavery
Arc at this point yeah but like but like
this is very specifically getting into
the details of like how slavery
depersonalizes the the other person and
dehumanizes them in order to
self-justify it and like you see that
and you're like I [__] I see where
you're doing Oda what do you think about
people who always try and claim that
anime is inherently non-political and
doesn't even remotely touch on like you
know people like it's
it is impossible for us to uh it is
impossible for us to remove ourselves
from politics because like every facet
of our existence is inherently political
whether we recognize it or not like what
you just described about health care for
example like to you the fact that you
have health care in Japan yeah versus
like Americans not having it like that
is a that is a political aspect of our
existence whether we vote or we don't
vote it doesn't matter it's still
happening so for that reason like
everyone develops their own uh ideas
about the world and how the world should
work or maybe even they have no ideas
about how the world should work at all
and just kind of let things slide in the
way that they currently exist even that
would be inherently political right so
it's just all art is going to have that
subtext it's impossible for it to be
completely removed from that completely
devoid of it and like I said
non-political like being non-political
uh because politics is is ever present
is still a political act inherently so
even that would be a a political
statement right you get a law backlash
whenever you talk about these kinds of
subjects where you were like I watch
this anime and this it's about this
political idea exploring this topic
um because I would imagine anime fans
Community not in my community because
like obviously this is what I do yeah
yeah but having said that I'm very uh
I'm not in the in the same team as like
a lot of people who go oh that's bad
like that's bad politics so you
shouldn't watch that you're a bad guy if
you enjoyed that I don't [__] with that
at all I think that that is completely
devoid of like uh what how you are in
your real life and like the call the
things that we consume do not make us
who we are yeah
um and I don't think that like cultural
things have the capacity to like
legitimately shift our at it it can
shift your attitude about the world it
can make you understand certain things
but it's not going to like all of a
sudden make people [__] extra uh you
know evil or extra good or anything like
that yeah
um so I'm not in the I'm usually not in
favor of like you know telling people
like you can't watch that that's bad and
you're a bad person so oftentimes that
is usually when people get mad at me
more is when I tell them like a piece of
content that you shouldn't consume is
not really all that you know it's not
really that game changing like you're
not making a political statement by
telling someone not to watch your thing
like that's just that's not politics
it's just you know you're just
personally stopping someone from
enjoying something boys and girls I have
a very simple question for you do you
want Grandma good then you've come to
the right place because this episode is
sponsored by grammarly when it comes to
work communication is key even if you
don't have a writing job such as myself
but regardless of whether you're a
struggling student or a working adult
you know that essays need to be written
emails need to be sent and DMS need to
be slid in into effortlessly and luckily
for all of that and everything else
grammarly is here to help because
grammarly can help with your
productivity and move your projects
along with ease for example I need to
send a lot of emails to clients like the
CEO that I am and grammarly premium's
confident tone suggestions ensure that I
come across as confident and as capable
as possible no more do I have to worry
about my English coming off as
incompetent thanks to Grandma not to
mention that grammarly is super easy to
integrate into your daily life it works
where you work such as Google Docs
Microsoft Word to ensure your tone is
coming across the way you want it to the
right tone can move your projects
forward with the help of grammarly go to
grammarly.com trash taste to sign up for
an account and if you'd like to level up
your writing and tone upgrade to
grammarly premium for 20 off that's
grambly.com trashcase links in the
description below back to the episode
watch chainsaw man recently by the way
I only watched the first two episodes
and I stopped immediately because I was
like I need to wait for the whole season
to come out and I haven't had time to
watch it now because I'm watching One
Piece
in 10 years then yeah yeah no but it's
it's sick like I I'm waiting for
Thriller bark almost like Snap me out of
it for a second and I was gonna like
that's when I watch Vinland Saga yeah
um but uh you know I
I I can't wait to watch it it's so it's
it's really sick yeah all right so like
now now that we've established that
you've actually watched a hell of a lot
of animals
yeah have you already mentioned those
that those are your favorites everything
you mentioned or is there anything else
that you really really love
um we talked about this last night but I
love uh like my top animes I was
thinking about this the other day is
like Cowboy Bebop Samurai shampoo and um
I said Attack on Titan but I think Space
Dandy too [__] that's how you know he's
a real life that's how you know man just
like your top three are from the same
director right uh created yeah
right I guess Yeah Yeah
from the same guy yeah yes you gotta go
you've got a guy yeah I I never really
like I never really thought about that
at all like who makes the animes at all
yeah until like recently when I started
getting a little bit I guess like
looking at it from a more adult
perspective speaking of alcohol well I'm
gonna derail this sir you should okay
okay I was just gonna say where it seems
like you know you're subconsciously
gravitated towards someone's style if a
lot of your favorite anime are by the
same director but what are you gonna say
come on do you watch hentai oh yeah good
question I have that was a real
derailment right there yeah I have okay
but I have suggestions okay okay I have
suggestions on jab two actually yeah
it's just typical like white guy comes
to Japan he's like this is how you
should do things no I just like I don't
understand it because like there's so
much in hentai that's just like so weird
to me maybe it's because like I don't
watch
concept of weird well I'm not even
talking about like the technical porn
stuff like that stuff is not even that's
the least weird that's not even like I'm
not even interested in that like it's
whatever but like normal hentai which is
supposed to like depict normal human
interactions for some reason always have
like the skinniest smallest dude with
like a woman that is like eight times
the dude's size with like and every time
she walks in the room her titties are
walking in for like a good two frames
before she gets into the room and like
that stuff is like kind of weird I'm
like make them look like anime
characters like why do you have to make
them so like bulbous and rotund right
other thing is like the x-ray vision I
can't stand that [__] yeah that is that
is some people like it some people don't
I cannot I'm like when
when have I have you ever like when
you're watching porn when have you ever
been like I wish I could cut them open
and see what they look like
I've never thought that in my life I see
that I'm like this is so medical you
know do you know what I think it is you
know I think it is but I just think a
lot of consumers of hentai have never
felt perverts have never felt what that
feels like so by having the internal
shot it's like yeah it's their
imagination of like I can kind of
imagine what it feels like it looks like
this it sounds like this and the
character is describing it like this
version right so I can yeah I can I can
go into that guy's mind being like it
probably feels like this yeah yeah I
just I see that I'm like gross yeah
it's so it's so yeah like I said it's
like medical like it's like a x-ray
vision like why do I need to see that
sometimes it gets two details yeah yeah
like like this like I didn't need to see
the ovaries like yeah I really did it
yeah it's like not sexual like that's
what I mean it's just yeah and then like
she's so large that she could just like
suck the entire dude into her [__]
basically and it's like what the [__]
like what is happening why can't they
have like normal proportions like it's
just [__] Attack on Titan all over
again right yeah just like you know
grown-up Hinata in the [__] you know
just do that that's I'm fine with that
like that that would be great yeah okay
uh mentioned the uh the types of genres
that it is it's more often than not uh
natural rare is the most popular one oh
I don't know the genre like I'm not that
into it like I'm not well if you watch
any you've probably come across it
because it's just it's unavoidable yeah
and then normally the ones that look the
best uh do you know what this is natural
no go ahead it's your field of expertise
expertise he knows he knows he knows no
because uh netarare is basically
pronounce it
um I guess how do I even describe this
it's kind of like [__] porn you you
basically it's it depicts like someone
who is in love with a girl all you know
in a relationship with a girl and he
watches her you know getting [__] uh
it's like really popular yeah and that's
like the most the most popular genre
here in Japan yeah most like any like
any type of like voyeurism is considered
like the top dog yeah oh yeah I saw the
binocular section at the [__] at the
big whatever is yeah big camera dude
that shit's crazy they just have an
entire like section dedicated but I was
like what the [__] I mean that's mostly
for bird watching my life
unless you're watching a different type
of bird yeah there was an old lady
when I was there she was like testing at
the bananas I was like okay I get what's
going on yeah I don't think she's a
pervert yeah
exactly exactly yeah have you been to
any anime stores since you've been yeah
yeah I I went to akiabara and it was
awesome did you did you go to any store
that had like a curtained off section no
I haven't seen like so people have sent
me what's the there's like a it's
yeah is like the guy who makes it is a
fan of mine yeah yeah he he like came to
me at the Anime Expo was like dude you
take all this like he like he like snuck
out and he gave me a bunch of like
fuckboo [__] yeah
um so I I've like you know people have
sent me like dojin's uh you know manga
in my uh in my P.O box before like I've
looked through it I just I can't like
it's too almost fascinating that I can't
like get into it you know what I mean I
don't know I don't think it's
fascinating I mean some people just
can't get into drawn like physical no I
want to bro I watch a lot of drawing
[__] like trust me yeah literally I'm
over here [__] Sweat Just dropping
down my brow I'm like come on man
so well okay so what was your what was
your contention on jav oh I mean I got a
lot I is so I mean I'm I'm very pro-sex
work I I actually uh I use a data a porn
star who like actually shot some uh porn
here in Japan too I'm friends with some
Japanese Sports I was like you know
raylo black uh being one of them even
though she doesn't shoot jav because she
has sex with black people and sometimes
that's like I guess not allowed okay jab
has like a lot of restrictions from what
I understand yeah from those friendly
secretive yeah it's like very very
um yeah it's very hardcore
um but other than that kind of stuff
other than like uh the actual sex
workers perspective on it as a consumer
like I want to well there's a couple
things one blurred penises and [__]
yeah yeah [__] that [__] yeah someone
needs to be like the brave guy who just
[__] fights for that in Japan
like someone he said he diesel yeah yeah
like someone needs to be like the guy
who's like oh yeah let's do it
anti-censorship law or something and not
to be that guy who's like all right
please vote for me by the way yeah my
main policies is for moving the place
don't make it the man sneak it in I I
think that would either like I think it
might work I think it could work or like
it would either backfire or immediately
get you elected there's no way
no I want to teach like I want to talk
to the Japanese people out here like I
know AOC in a bunch of AOC and a bunch
of like American politicians like came
to Japan recently like right as I was uh
coming in yeah yeah because I was I was
actually gonna originally do a podcast
with her here because I was like
thinking like you know we're both here
we'll link up here yeah then I was like
what the [__] I can just do it in
America it doesn't matter
um but they came and talked to some
politicians and I was like [__] I want
to be one of those envoys who like
teaches uh you know sneaky ways of
earmarking things into bills you know
what I mean go to the wait how do you
say is it diet or diet diet I think diet
yeah yeah just go to the diet and just
[__]
pass legislation that is completely
unrelated but then hide that [__] in
there you know
yeah I would like to say something yeah
yeah just sneak it in
even mention it everyone will be like
wink wink nod like No One's Gonna Do and
they're not killing orphan bills I did
sneak in a no blurring Pawn rule yeah
Sue me yeah and then because this always
works in America because then if people
say oh wow this is there's a no dick
there's a dick blurring law in here you
could be like you want orphans to die
like nobody nobody wants to be against
the don't murder orphansville you know
what I mean yeah wow you want to talk
about unrelated things like dicks and
[__] that's kind of weird bro we're
talking about not killing orphans here
so you have to do that
um so that's one problem I have with jab
and then the other one is like they just
look so sad
I think they look so sad when they're
doing it that that is one problem I have
as well they they look and sound like
they're in pain yeah yeah and it's like
it's not hot yeah I've never been able
to fire one off the jab for that reason
like I want to because like the actors
are beautiful they're like three hours
long so it's yeah it's way harder to
like scrub through it yeah they've had
that [__] out like a dragon bowler yeah
some jobs for trying to like put a
proper storyline in there dude this Jabs
that are like full-on like episodic
Series yeah and that has like a a an a
plot and a b plot yeah it's like saying
how much work they put into the story
how much they care about that but I
ain't got three hours of me to jack off
now oh well they also need to man the
camera works so bad they need to get
some like American Producers out here
like go to I agree with that too like
the angles are not doing anybody
favorite no there's just always terrible
there's a lot the amateur thing kind of
works though I don't know maybe it works
in the favor for it maybe I mean clearly
I mean it must be like it's very very
successful and very popular in Japan so
it's very popular I think in China as
well oh really really well in China yeah
I think I think China has like started
doing their own like they they marketed
as job I think but it's not but it's not
like and and they they don't have they
don't censor it because I've seen that
that's how you tell the difference yeah
no literally like they I think they they
do that and then another thing I know
like they they shoot it in the
Philippines sometimes right like they'll
get like Japanese actresses to shoot in
the Philippines so they can like
override the jab rules oh [__] yeah I
know a lot about the mechanics of porn
and because of like my tricks you're
like God the [__] Supply dude no no
no it's just like I know about it
because I got my advocacy for sex work
so like it's it's very it's very
detailed and very interesting when you
think about it but as a consumer when I
look at it I'm just like bro you are so
sad yeah like I can't I don't want to
jerk off I want to help you like what's
going on
what's happening like I'm I'm expecting
like a taken style situation for like
Liam Neeson burst through the door it
doesn't have to be a white guy but like
you know burst through the door and like
saves her and then they [__] in a loving
way you know what I mean yeah I never
understood Japanese censorship laws when
it comes to like pornography yeah
because you look at some stuff that in
hentai and someone like something like
the most [__] up decrepit [__] you can
think of but don't shoot the penis
what's that what's the originated from
certainly with America or something
being involved I can't believe it was
see I'm trying I'm trying to remember
because I remember I they covered this
in naked director yeah I feel like they
changed it preemptively I think I
thought it predates like uh even like
post World War II Japan I thought it was
like yeah because all the all the
traditional paintings
it's like the kind of like the
pornographic paintings from like the Edo
period we're all wrong everything was
out too much too much in America
instilled puritanical values Japan too
that's so [__] up
yeah well the reason technical hentai
exist was because that was that yeah
their way to get around censorship
because which is why I thought it was it
predates it because I thought hentai
existed before like uh tentacle porn
existed right well the tentacle concept
was from this ukulele from I think it's
like the 1700s yeah yeah yeah
um yeah but like I think uh yeah when
when the modern stuff came out yeah yeah
because like back back in that painting
the tentacles didn't look like penises
well they figured out that they could
make something look yeah if something
looks like a penis but technically isn't
a penis we don't need to blur that out
yeah and so that was the way they got
around that yeah that's [__] up like
that's just like that's that sucks they
just show the penises yeah like also
just like some of some of the hentai and
like JV I've seen the sensory is just so
lazy to the point where it's like it's
no secret what's behind the scenes yeah
like I know what's happening it's so bad
for the Judas the sensor three yeah yeah
because you look at the sun ship and you
realize that's someone's job
frame by frame yeah
thing is is that it's it's not like you
said I get lazy but like the the actual
like blurring because if you ever had to
blow a video yeah you know it's not easy
to get the shapes yeah oh yeah and they
are doing it like as little as possible
because customers get angry yeah and
it's like just the right amount of
pixels and they're moving it all the
time like yeah it's just psychotic
millions of frames I'm surprised the
editors haven't had an uprising and
lobbied you can tell you sometimes you
see a JV and you can tell that uh the
censorship guy definitely loved their
jobs because you can always tell there's
always the the air the surface area of
the sun ship some are just like cutting
it close some are just like we're just
gonna cover half the [__] boy
whatever man I don't get paid enough
this year that's a master in his craft
yeah right
said it was America well they did it
like preemptively Central America no
they they like
around the same America's done a lot of
[__] up [__] that you paid
not a controversial take
one of the uh
the censoring that was like so the Meiji
period the Pacific War didn't have
to censor like a lot of like yeah so
it's the major restoration right which
is basically where Japan started
incorporating Western like uh you know
political uh values and stuff like that
that is the most common that is
literally the entire planet like you're
like even I mean I've talked about this
before not to get too political but like
I talk about this on my stream all the
time or like
homosexuality for example in like the
ottoman era in turkey or even in like
the Mena region was not even considered
like it was just like normal mode of
existence you know people are gay who
gives a [__] whatever and it's like
Western attitudes that that against
homosexuality uh that that stem back to
like I guess the the Dark Ages and you
know wanting to make sure that like you
know a
father and a wife like a you know a
father and a mother stayed together
instead of like going out in [__]
dudes uh so that they could have as many
children as possible so they could
repopulate at a time when like children
were just like dying Non-Stop and you
needed more Farm hands that culture and
that attitude absolutely uh it was was
the reason why so many so many cultures
even all the way out here in the Far
East are are uh homophobic yeah like I'm
not educated enough on this no yeah it's
just it's interesting to think about
that like it's so it's such a powerful
uh it's such a powerful thing that you
know you just slowly but surely change
the way people view their you know daily
existence and then they take it on
themselves and and you know and that's
how you get blurred dicks and penises in
Japanese adult video God damn it it's
[__] up that's it's all those farmers
in the Dark Ages man if it wasn't for
them yeah we would have been will see
everything it's like the Domino meme
it's like farmers in the Dark Ages
yeah it's [__] up yeah Jesus it's the
church man they need to they [__]
ruined everything
yeah because citizenship had a well back
in the top of our period as well it's
like Christianity is like so they have
to sense it yeah and bad all those books
away from people oh yeah yeah okay
yeah that's [__] up so we've been here
for like over an hour and a half now we
haven't asked you how your time in
Japan's been yet oh yeah you've been
living your best weed life yeah dude so
I love it dude it's just it seems insane
that like people just live here and like
what do you mean by that what do you
mean by that it's wild dude like people
just [__] straight up go to work and
like and and live here when you think
about it I'm like everything is awesome
that is the most weeb thing you've said
you want the biggest
we
know which is like thing thing in Japan
it's like oh no but like it is like that
you don't understand it no literally it
is like that it's I don't know what it
is like I I mean there's a magic to it I
think it's not supposed to work like
Japan is not supposed to work but it
works somehow I don't know just
everything is
um everything that I would normally look
to with like my political understandings
and like everything I know about the
world like Japan basically took on and
was like no no we'll make it work and it
does somehow like you have 3 800
homeless people in the entire [__]
Island but like at the same time it's
not like the country's doing really well
economically right you know what I mean
younger Generations are very frustrated
with a lack of opportunity people are
just not dying so much so that you got
[__] Japanese Yale economists talking
about how like oh I have a solution kill
yourself to the older people you know
what I mean you have all this [__]
that's like so it you have uh what I
would consider to be like oh my goodness
that's just my phone you have what I
would consider to be like a ticking Time
Bomb you know what I mean like
capitalism is like hyper capitalist but
it's it's held together by like
thousands of years of like rigid
structure and tradition in like
unflinching in the face of like uh you
know a a world that uh is is constantly
being like no no things should be very
different like things should be more
free so in some ways it's shitty like
with the you know the hentai stuff
on social issues sensitive like blurring
of the penises of vaginas like that's
weird
but but also at the same time I think
like that is still the reason why you
know you have such an emphasis on like
cleaning your own space making sure that
you have uh making sure that you leave
the place better than you you uh then
you first yeah it's a very like uh I
would say like collectivist but like
that collectivist Society creates like
very uh like uh selfless people oh yeah
yeah you know where it's like it's I'm
I'm at the bottom of the priority and
everybody else is above me kind of thing
right so it's like that and when
everybody is like that then everyone's
looking out for each other yeah yeah
which is crazy because at the same time
it's like insanely capitalist so you're
like how the [__] does this work because
in America we're insanely capitalist is
a hyper capitalist dystopia but then
also people are hyper individualists so
when you have that that's when you get
to like no Health Care everybody has a
gun you know full Freedom yeah you have
the freedom to like die from uh you know
not getting your your diseases treated
right right but um but you don't have
that in Japan you have the economic
structure which I think is like wild uh
and and you know inherently incredibly
exploitative but then it still somehow
works and I still haven't figured out
exactly what the [__] going on like I
don't know how it works I don't even
think Japan's figured that [__] out
there like just like it it doesn't make
any sense because like I mean I guess
that's why they called it a post-war
economic Miracle right yeah yeah well I
think a lot of people just take a lot of
uh a lot of Pride and a lot of care and
what they do in a way that is kind of
hard to expect of people in Western
countries because we'd be like [__] that
I'm not working and yeah McDonald's for
five [__] dollars an hour yeah yes I
think in Japan there's not really that
concept of you know [__] your employer
for not paying you enough this is like
no such you take what you're given right
yeah I mean yeah but also like how do
they survive you know what I mean like
that's the other that's what I'd
understand we you guys have talked about
uh you know like anime uh not voice
actors obviously but like the the yeah
the animators like how the [__] do they
survive by doing multiple jobs
or you know as you might have noticed
over one is overworking or stuff is
really cheap in Japan that's true you
want to live off literally the bad
Essentials you can kind of do it pretty
cheap in Japan yeah you won't live well
but you can survive you know that that
that does blow my mind like because
housing you know what I mean like that's
a huge problem yeah yeah that is a big
problem in Tokyo yeah yeah uh and not
even just in Tokyo but like I just I I
don't understand how um you they spend
so much less money overall and yet like
this is a this is an issue that they've
been able to
not fully eradicate obviously no I mean
the economy certainly still do a lot
better than America in some aspects yeah
I think so yeah
um the the best example is like is the
the railway system right yeah it's a
Marvel obviously it's like uh originally
it's government funded because you have
to do it like that that's a massive
infrastructure project you have to get
the government and the tax dollars to
pay for it right yeah but also now it's
like fully privatized yeah so that's the
reason why you see like uh so many
Railway uh switches in between and like
all this like frustrating uh all these
like frustrating things that you
experience without even realizing why
it's happening well that's because it's
owned by like multiple different uh
multiple different companies right
um but it still [__] works yeah yeah
it still works it's not supposed to in
America those trains will be [__]
eating each other every day they would
literally be like hitting each other
non-stop the most inconvenience you get
in Japan in terms of it being different
companies competing is that yeah so you
have to change Gates yeah yeah so you're
gonna be on the Metro you have to clock
you have to go yeah yeah that's what I
that's what I mean literally they'll
like bare minimum and that's crazy when
you have like uh such a you know
intricate system and and yet the trains
[__] run on time yeah that's what I
mean it's not supposed to be that way
like it doesn't make sense you go to the
UK
uh a lot of places where Railway is
nationalized have privatized shouts at
the Margaret Thatcher that [__] [__]
um
no no no no no of course not no exactly
so like that privatization has genuinely
destroyed like what is otherwise
something that people hold on to as a
Lifeline because like if you're poor
that's the one thing you have you know
what I mean like that's how you travel
um we don't even have that in America so
like that's a foreign concept public
transit is like not even a thing yeah
um and and you see that like
privatization is supposed to destroy uh
uh the the uh things that otherwise
government should be able to handle but
in Japan it just [__] works and it
works really well and it like blows my
mind when I watch it when I see it well
I I think that's just a general kind of
like culture in Japan where what no
matter what your job is you should take
pride in your work to make it the best
they can possibly be and that translates
to every single aspect of Japanese
culture whether you be [__] by buying
fruits from the supermarket or going to
a restaurant or getting any kind of
craftsmanship yeah it doesn't always
work there are a lot of things that
Japan is definitely not caught on to
um just like adopting to the online uh
world is tough or the receipt system
yeah yeah why like yo you're using paper
like yeah yeah when I did my taxes I
have to I have to scan every receipt and
upload them that is insane dog that
makes no sense like it makes no sense
right they're just playing on hard mode
like what the [__] and like you know
even though you mentioned the trains
like there are certain trains if you
want to book them where it becomes like
a you know a doom like a dark souls one
hit level of difficulty it's like it's
for no reason like just some things that
just didn't quite adapt the way they
should have and it ends up making this
kind of really [__] up Amalgamated
system of like booking and stuff that
doesn't quite work right but it works if
you know how to do it because people are
pretty persistent here if they want
something I mean even just doing like
general paperwork in this country is the
most like asinine thing ever right
because everything is layered behind 10
layers of paperwork but you could you
could uh oh I know I had to [__]
write like all the forms to like get
into the country yeah yeah it's not
gonna have the option of then he was
super easy
yeah
no it's not easy at all
all to a government building you could
just walk in you can just see where all
the Walkers are the Stacks and stacks of
papers yeah because they're all working
analogs this can't be efficient no it's
not and it's not it's so hard for
bookkeeping you can't search like you
you could just search on if you
modernize it yeah it makes no sense yeah
they're so that's that's that sort of
stuff also is like very strange to me
that they're they're like nope we're
gonna keep using paper well again it's
that whole idea of like holding on to
tradition yeah
elderly people yeah but the systems
there is a positive to that because like
it probably and I don't even know this
uh is the case or not but I suspect that
it probably keeps certain economies
alive oh for sure the more the more you
like stick to paper for example the more
you like literally have the have you
guys ever seen the office yeah the
American version like Dunder Mifflin
going out of business because no one
uses paper anymore yeah but you have
like what is it is it Muji like there's
like companies that just like make pay
paper products yeah but then they also
like become conglomerates and also sell
like vibrators and [__] too on the side
which is wild that's like a very that is
a very like uh you know uh East Asian
country thing to have like I think at
least the government as well I think a
lot of the priority is just keeping jobs
yeah and fortunately to if you want to
modernize things it only means you
either gotta move people around or
figure out something new yeah and that's
that's tough uh also Japan is just like
in general really bad at adopting new
things oh yeah terrible yeah like
occasionally they'll take something like
a toilet and I'll be like we're up in
the game yeah and other stuff they'll be
like ooh they're like but we're keeping
the fax machine just in case yeah I mean
we've just started I've just started
seeing contactless like payment machines
yeah
oh my God I have to [__] have like a
coin wallet like I have a coin wallet
too yeah that's insane like there's this
oh no I don't want any of that man I
can't keep it yeah and it makes keeping
bookkeeping like you mentioned hard
because I have to then keep all the
receipts yeah and I have no trail of it
existing if it's if I lose that exactly
that that kind of stuff is crazy like
that that that definitely blows my mind
um but overall it's there not to weeb
out too much but you can weave out it is
it is very it is beautiful like business
there's problems and as every country
does but there but there's so much good
here yeah so much amazing it's so
beautiful like that's what I mean when I
they're like [__] are just
going to work and I'm just sitting there
like looking around
that's crazy you
know you're so sick you know what I mean
yeah yeah which probably is like a
byproduct of me being here for the first
time and like anime definitely breaking
my brain I mean it definitely like for I
think the big one that we've always
mentioned about a bunch of the podcast
is like vending machines wear off yeah
they will real quick yeah
like a coffee machine uh the vending
machine coffee I I remember moving after
moving to Japan I thought I would get
those kinds of coffees every day uh when
I was a tourist I would like go to the
vending machine in the morning get a
coffee and I'd be like this is it this
is the life moved here didn't drink it
at all no no I I I I understand like
that that's not I'm not that fascinated
with the vending machines but it's like
a very easy example yeah yeah but oh my
God the [__] the the 7-Elevens dude
holy [__] I will say that is one thing
that never seems to like I never seem to
I always appreciate it yeah egg salad
dude it's like it's just so good and
you'll appreciate it more if you ever
leave Tokyo because you'll be in the
middle of nowhere middle of nowhere in
Japan you're like an hour away from
anywhere restaurant but there'll be a
7-Eleven fully stocked yeah every food
24 7 as well it's like this is just the
BET like if you go to rural uh Wales
it's like good luck yeah
there's no food maybe there's a Greg's
three hours from you but there's no food
yeah yeah and then the shops shut at
four so if you don't have food by four
and you know you're just you're just
[__] like four on certain days it
depends on the story the point is yeah
you can't you don't get food like that
yeah okay it's just convenient in it
yeah it's something that we've
definitely taken for granted UK still
kind of looks like Vinland Saga honestly
I mean yeah Danes did a number on them
yes
um I but other than that uh you know I I
feel like I'm experiencing Japan right
now at like 10 because I can't see me
yeah because one I'm in Tokyo so like
that's you know there's so much more
yeah but also uh because I can't speak
Japanese right so in in many respects I
feel like I'm literally for the first
time in my life because I've been in
Western Europe a lot like I grew up in
Turkey you know I live in America now
all around America I visited
I feel like a [__] alien like I feel
like I'm an alien that just landed on a
on you know another planet yeah that
just kind of really looks like my Planet
yeah with people that kind of look a lot
like me as well but I can't understand
anything right and it's so shocking
because like with the Latin alphabet you
really take it for granted you don't go
anywhere you go anywhere else like you
can still kind of make sense of like
what you go to Germany I don't speak
German but like I can make sense of like
what I'm looking at yeah but with like
kanji I'm like what the [__] what
there's so much it's like blocks of text
I'm like what am I looking at it's like
it like hurts my brain and yet it's
still so much fun at the same time so
I'm like I'm thinking like you know if I
learned even a little bit of Japanese
which I feel like is how it starts oh
yeah like you know when you were being
like whoa white boy swag I'm like this
is just a script yeah I've gone to
Starbucks so much coffee I know every
single dial log options you you should
make a YouTube compilation
I was like what is he was talking about
uh you know the guy who goes is it loud
wires Chinese and then they go all the
Chinese people go like whoa oh yeah yeah
it just doesn't work no no oh you speak
Japanese good as you [__] shoot you
get any hunger jokes
but like you know they don't they don't
freak out because they're not like um
like I don't know they're not like
characters
well well I don't think that the Chinese
people are like that I think he's just
like Faking It for the most part yeah he
orders in perfect fluid Mandarin flow
shopkeepers mine it's like okay
yeah it's just like because for some
reason [__] I was on that stream with
you and someone uploaded the clip and
then the comments were roasting me
because they were like he's literally
just saying Japanese English words
but it's so sick because like when you
speak Japanese one your voice drops okay
and two you have a list
you don't have a list normally when
you're speaking English but when you
speak Japanese you're like uh
I don't know
this is like side effects from being
fluent in Welsh and Sh is pronounced
like shh yeah it could be I don't know
well like my Japanese is more closer to
I think like my Thai accent than my
Japanese accent because when I speak
Thai my voice goes like up like two
octaves I don't know why I think it
might just be easier for a tonal
language that it goes up to octaves
um well yeah I've heard my Japanese like
my voice gets a lot higher when I speak
Japanese yeah but like when you say it
you don't notice it yeah what about with
you like it does it change it with
Turkish yeah
um definitely yeah people say I sound
like way more aggressive that's just
Turkish yeah yeah I guess
yeah like I'll be I'll I'll say like you
know I love you to my mom or something
in Turkish people like what the [__]
like why are you yelling
yeah like how do you appear like that it
doesn't sound like that it was about
like okay I'll kiss you mom you know
yeah yeah that's how you say like I see
you
um Japan is the opposite yeah Japan is
Japan is like it's like I'll kill you
yeah it's like oh my God yeah yeah
people say things very polite but
they'll like they'll literally be saying
it but they won't even be saying bad
things but they'll be the context of
yeah saying is like I will [__]
murder you yeah for me I feel like it's
really nice because of watching so much
anime and also because I speak Turkish
when I say things in Japanese I feel
like I'm saying it wrong like I was like
and it's like that's not how you're
supposed to say bye I don't think you
know it's not like yeah yeah yeah
this is a pretty you could probably have
a slightly easier time picking a
Japanese up because you're bilingual
yeah it helps I feel like it does yeah
um there's a lot of Cinema
yes you do
do you think Tokyo would be better if it
focused a little bit more on making it
like more Foreigner friendly or would
you think it's like this is no this is
it I don't think I mean I think like
ease of access is good like at least use
like Latin alphabet in places yeah but I
don't think roads but I don't think they
should do that I don't think they should
because I've always had this like really
interesting thought because you know I
come from Thailand and we've made our uh
We've made our you know cities very very
easy to like visit and very foreign and
friendly and I'm like we try to keep as
much as the culture as we can but there
are some things like you know Bangkok
isn't even like the Thai name of like
Thailand
um sorry Bangkok isn't the Thai name of
the city
um it's actually grunteer which
is harder to say for yeah westerners
which is actually not the full name oh
yeah isn't it name of Thailand like
super [__] law I think it's actually
like the longest city name yeah in the
world he knows all about that [__] bro
yeah oh that's not the longest city but
it's just a long name so yeah dude come
on that oh
so okay so I think I can remember the
Thai full name for Bangkok
so it is
I'm serious I am serious what could you
be saying in that lens it's basically
describing the city so so you know you
know how like in you know you know Game
of Thrones where they you know introduce
like the Khaleesi Mother of Dragons yeah
yeah all this stuff so it's it's kind of
like that oh that's sick yeah so nailed
that I think I don't know yeah yeah
I feel like that gets real tough if
you're just trying to be like where are
you staying and then you just like how
much time do you have yeah it's just
like you're on the 9-1-1 call and it's
like oh so where are you staying now can
you imagine like going through
immigration and being like where are you
where are you embarking from
that makes sense but like we I believe
like we had to change the name I don't
know if I'm making this up but like we
obviously shortened it but no Thai
person calls like the uh no shot yeah
that one they just call that standard PG
most of the time yeah
that's pretty long yeah it's hard though
because it's just like an unnatural way
to talk I think for most yes bro Welsh
is like why the [__] do you have so many
throw sounds like what's happening Welsh
is the most like can I buy a vowel
please similar like throttle uh I mean
we have uh but that's like it we have
like uh yumusha which is like a soft G
so it's like a g with like a thing on it
yeah yeah but like those are some of the
sounds but we don't have like like
anywhere like that it's just like well
it's just like Double L is
it's like kind of the sides like talking
that's that's a crazy thing yeah that's
cool because you're like right there
next to England yeah yeah that's what
makes it crazy we were around before
English no I know crushing it I I didn't
do it then we didn't crush it well I
know but it's still like crazy that you
know it's the it's the common language
and you're like so close and you have
like insane sounds that just sounds so
different they really thought to keep it
around I'm kind of glad they did because
you know compared to it's it's a lot
more prevalent in Wales than it isn't
say like how Gaelic is an island or uh
and same in Scotland it's yeah there's a
lot more speakers and it's taking a lot
more seriously I think it's really cool
I mean I think Traditions I think is
like the more grow older and especially
being in Japan the more I think there
are some traditions that if you try to
like go with you know uh if you try to
like lose some tradition to be more
accommodating sometimes you can lose you
can lose a lot of charm yeah that name
gotta change though that name yeah that
needed a chance
I I like uh Japan the way it is
um why am i gatekeeping Japan
yeah
you've reached the final stage of like
weeabooism now you're like no no no I
think I'm basically Japanese at this
point they should they should definitely
like you know the ease of access if you
want to like you know fix the the Aging
population problem like you have to have
immigration of course yeah well that's
going to be hard to get votes yeah yeah
which is crazy when you think about it
like but you know they
like integration is definitely a a
component in a multicultural world and I
feel like Japanese people do not give a
[__] about that no no they're just like
oh you're not gonna integrate I don't
give a [__] [__] you I don't even want
you here so is there anything you want
to shout out I stream on Twitch every
day
yeah it's insane yeah even even in Japan
I've been waking up at six you know
streaming for eight hours every day yeah
but uh obviously go check out Hassan's
stuff Link in the description and uh
look at all these patrons though oh my
God you see all of them look at those
all over on the screen wow who's your
favorite
which one's your favorite one yeah that
that one right there lucky year if
you're gonna point it out but uh Hey if
you like to support us then go over to
our patreon patreon.com trash taste also
follow us on Twitter send us a memes on
the subreddit and if I had a face listen
to us on Spotify and uh thanks for
coming son yeah thank you thanks for
having me yeah this is awesome yeah hell
yeah people are forcing these boys to
talk about anime for once it's
impossible I thought yeah I heard this
is the number one anime podcast that
never talks about anime hell yeah and
that's what I was excited for yeah
oh yeah see you guys bye
[Music]